the Israeli airstrikes began just after
two o'clock in the morning 40 aircraft
struck targets across the Gaza Strip
the focus was the homes of three
commanders from Palestinian Islamic
Jihad
Israel says that they had been
responsible for attacks on Israel in
recent weeks
weapons factories and storage facilities
were also hit
four women and four children were among
the dead twenty were wounded some of
those also civilians
the funerals were held in Gaza this
afternoon
is
lives next door to one of the Islamic
Jihad Commanders two of her daughters
Danya and Iman were killed when the
missiles hit the building Iman was 16
and Dania was 19 and due to get married
in July
um
Israel says it was a precise targeted
military operation and described the
Islamic Jihad commanders as Kingpin
terrorists but they did admit that
civilians had also been killed
Israeli towns and Villages bordering
Gaza were put on alert residents were
told to stay indoors or close to bomb
shelters outdoor Gatherings were banned
and approval was given for Israeli
military reservists to be called up if
needed the country is braced for a
retaliation
Alistair bunkel Sky News in Jerusalem